ladies and gentlemen I'm joined by Tim
breaks from worried programming and we
dominate nutrition welcome thank you you
may remember Tim from such episodes as
why does Fitness hurt so much and can
you teach mental toughness yeah
they were massive and very opinionated
incredibly opinionated driven by opinion
that's exactly what it is and exactly
will to me it's just the same it's just
a replicant so today we're gonna be
talking about how to eat for performance
yes particularly for me I'm interested
in this I know how to eat to get lean
but yeah if you were to say you've got a
powerlifting meet next weekend then
you've got an endurance event the
weekend after and then you've got a
CrossFit competition that weekend after
that what would you eat and why I I
wouldn't have a clue I wouldn't know the
first places so that's so the athlete
will be our ages do a powerlifting me
and did he say like it what was the last
one is that the CrossFit event and then
a like a in June like a marathon us and
a Mars and probably not gonna need to be
jolly well this thing yeah if you tossin
wallets job mothers can do all those
things yeah the power a little bit and I
joke and you think got my power so we're
gonna talk about that is there a basis
to start from an understanding sports
nutrition yet so the way we approach
nutrition we look at health first so we
look at the micros as well as the
overall energy balance and that's where
we start
every athlete that does we don't make
nutrition so we look at all the
efficiencies we look how we can kind of
manipulate the micronutrients as well as
a macro nutrients the micros are the
vitamins and minerals if you have
deficiencies on those the energy is
going to be affected you're gonna be
quite lethargic your recovery is going
to be down and that can all be targeted
through food so we can look at eating a
variety veggies even the whole spectrum
of colors of fruit and veg maybe
supplement with a green shake maybe even
a volt multivitamin and that's where we
kind of start things
we've got those deficiencies we're gonna
be down long-term when we do get to
these competitions okay so starting with
the micro to me seems quite contrary to
what I would have heard in the past yes
like macros are all they are that's yeah
like hashtag calorie [ __ ] deficit
yeah so I don't get me wrong we do you
start with giving the overall energy to
try and reach the metabolic baseline
that's what we kind of call the tdee
it's a total daily energy expenditure
yeah so we call it an emetic baseline
where we just kind of take into account
daily activity sport thermogenesis
things like that so energy that you're
gonna burn it and how much off but with
the TDE it's a little bit skewed for
CrossFit because it doesn't really take
in account the intensity of it it's more
like if you sat on the bike for 45
minutes and lift fairly said this in
real life
whereas everybody those CrossFit these
days they're probably stand of deaths
probably got little pedals and standing
up for CrossFit life and probably run to
lunch and things like that yeah they'll
go to the CrossFit class they'll stretch
the form roll their probably sit on the
bike 10 15 minutes before the class both
jump in they'll start to get warm again
with the class then the heart rates
gonna be throughout with our kind of
like workouts are gonna be high
intensity so we'll get our heart rate up
to 90% of your heart rate over the three
minutes if it is front then your heart
rate is going to be further for a lot
more than three minutes and your
Energy's gonna be through the roof
if you consumed yeah whereas if you just
start on a bike it's just gonna be a lot
more study away I learn effective yeah
the afterburn effect will probably last
30 40 50 minutes depending on how hard
you go yeah and I would say and that
hole and fit you are cool so you start
with the micro yes cool and you said
follow the veggies and yeah
spectrum of foods yeah like that
so how do you ensure that I'm gonna
guess that we're talking at this stage
about an athlete that's just in training
yes as opposed in prepping for a comp so
yeah it everybody kind of been a comp
prep mode regardless of where you are so
kind of treat everybody the say you
might have a comp coming over six eight
weeks we look at your overall kind of
food intake and we'll kind of coach you
through which veggies to eat which
deficiencies you may have
we're not firmly gonna understand
without any Bloods taken if you do have
these massive deficiencies Buddha's
gonna try and overload on these as a
result what's the staple foods that you
go to to kind of get all of these things
up or why do you know it's deficiencies
most commonly with your other just
complete lack of greens going funny but
like we are we when my athletes check in
is always like a food quality scale then
there's how many portions of your micros
of eaten on a daily basis I always
notice at the start it's a mess you like
one to two and we try and prize a little
bit more out of them then go for
different colors and satisfy different
micro ranges it sounds like you're
trying to train a Naughty Dog exactly
you know you like it for first we're
gonna get into we like on them yet and
then we're gonna get into we in the
garden and then you can we on the field
outside or 100 be on the field of I've
been through that as you have actually
still wheeze on the carpet so if someone
is thinking that sounds a lot like me
yeah I am struggling to get greens into
my diet that um my hand goes in the air
for that as well what are some bits of
advice that you can give for how people
can slide into the cooking schedule and
their eating schedule without it being
too kind of impacting on their normal
routine too much first up I would go for
a green shake in the Mon there's a few
variations on how you can do this you
get greens powder any way you can kind
of get it from or you can kind of make
your own link will be in the show notes
below to the protein works they do a
fantastic greens powder and also if you
use the code
there is link to the show notes below
you hope you're able to get 30% off
everything on the site great prep there
we go yes so you can use protein works
greens yep
actually odd yeah oh we can make our own
so we can throw some spinach some
beetroot just tons of veggies in a shake
flips it up might not be that tasty but
you'll knock a few portions of your
micros out for the day then move on to
your breakfast how a handful of spinach
really breakfast then look at your prep
meals throughout the day try and balance
amount so it's like one-third protein
one third of carbohydrate one third of
veggies and if you have that balanced
throughout every meal probably gonna be
there there abouts so that's the very
kind of rough low resolution but I'll
you know I think trying to micro micro
manage these meals with this amount of
this particular food and yeah things
like that so you only treat just saying
aim to split your meals uppers protein
carbs yeah veg yes through as each of
the thirds yeah and then where are fats
coming in fats will probably be with you
meats all they'll be living with you
food maybe a little bit after you can
have a knock bar for instance this is
just with kind of like a prep meal yeah
fill up the hardest to get fast in there
you can throw up a card or in front of
the range of my girls I hate on a card
it's all slice it isn't it like a lot of
people love it a lot of people hate it
or Emami very Maui the father's well you
reckon it's a massive fight I only found
out recently how it expensive
avocado is in Australia you're expensive
is like crazy women true
I don't really know conversion rate what
it's it's like I think over 1000 dollars
so about 10 pounds for a single avocado
that's mod it's just apparently they're
really hard to get hold of when
Australia is in the middle of nowhere
but they also love bubble toast I don't
know that it's a from avocado on toast
are okay sorry just down with kids yeah
I know you all have combining words
into a new foods type I devote else
today I'm not gonna like God and so
we've looked at the micro yeah and then
what about you you've said that the
macro in terms of I guess the way that
you're piecing together in those foods
but if you're doing a sport and I'm
gonna presume the people that are
listening will be doing some form of
strength work ya know there will be the
full spectrum from people that are doing
powerlifting to people that are doing
endurance work but there must be some
commonalities there everybody needs to
cover someone observe and most people
probably need the same things which is
carbohydrates okay more sports so we
talked about this our thinking our first
one we ever did we're like an energy
systems chart so if you look at what
sport you do and you piece it on the
chart there's very few where they're
gonna go for like Iron Man's and it will
use fatty acids towards the end that's a
finishing point if we move through it'll
go a little bit more aerobic they'll go
glycolytic and then it'll go ATP and
phosphocreatine
okay so that's sort of we're talking
about length of we're consideration is
this is duration and intensity video
Gardein if you are watching any achieve
I'm sure video coding will be able to
make a chart appear in front of Tim's
face as he's talking about it there you
go you can see these electrons just
right there just right there so when we
look at that we can apiece your spot on
there CrossFit is in that glycolytic
zone so we'll be using carbohydrates as
a main fuel source if we go a little bit
further down with the strongman
powerlifting it will be ATP and phosphor
creatine which is pretty so that it will
be your red meats your creatine
monohydrate which is fueled by on the
line from carbohydrate right so and then
as you move down you're going into
CrossFit you more carbohydrate again
yeah they've forgotten endurance for it
will be more carbohydrate a little bit
of fussy outlet fatty acid then if
you've got a major major major endurance
don't just be fatty acids with
carbohydrate as well so you're talking
like Durance
if you look at the whole spectrum yep
carbohydrate is throughout yes so that's
what you'll need to fill your body with
as an athlete is carbohydrate
so how are people getting away with
doing ultras on kids it like oh it's mad
they all just stood up like that with
looking at the literature with a lot
that's came out recently there's a
debate with it the donkey toes he's
probably not the best way to go to get
yourself in a zone where your body goes
I'm gonna eat myself to fuel your race
yeah it's a mmm probably not the best
way to do this maybe is someone who is
an avatar for the layperson when it
comes to understanding sports nutrition
yeah it doesn't sound like a good thing
it's not great because carbohydrates
have a lot of benefits for the liver for
the muscle i just brain house of justice
they provide energy yet the provide
energy provide energy for the body yep
the major fuel source for your muscles
so when you're trying to run for several
hours without any carbohydrate which is
what keep Genesis means is your body now
doesn't rely what carbohydrate just fat
and it's and the internal sources it's
not probably not the best way to go
about it
that's just from my opinion should there
be those who say keto is the way to go
or works for them or works for them I
mean I'm yet to see any power lifters or
strongmen come out there doing a keto no
it's definitely not the way to go like
even when all's not going keto even when
people got paleo there's a massive paleo
rush for CrossFit yeah alright hey Leo
briefly explain what paleo is hey Leo is
basically how what you need if you're a
caver so ok forgetting about the fact
we've evolved quite a lot we've now got
supermarkets around the street weaned in
pop foods we could have a vast variety
of foods so they think the best way to
go is what would be readily available
round here if there wasn't the
supermarket
okay so it's trying to basically but
then obviously you gotta go the co-op
you gonna get to either gonna get your
stuff to be a barrier so it's a
simulacrum of yeah we would have had
during our the broader period of our
genetic history the argument is that
recently we are able to graze at periods
of frequency that are unnatural we're
able to have foods that have only become
available recently yeah and that in the
past we wouldn't have had that therefore
there is some degree of credence that's
lent to this older style of ancestral
yeah diet nuts berries
I'm gonna guess there'll be some in um
in fasting and stuff like that in
probably yeah it's not really with the
guidelines but I guess the really
hardcore people will in if' as well yeah
so a day they'll probably have to go for
a hunt or something the more a good ski
one of the check out so ok so that you'd
mentioned about paleo was one of there
yes
so paleo it's you can't get
carbohydrates from out I think the love
sweet potato on that but often you don't
get enough you don't get enough to fill
your body especially with CrossFit is so
glycolytic you are using your
carbohydrates from whole thing whether
you're lifting whether you're in a make
on whatever you're doing your
carbohydrate is the main fuel source so
to go with out carbohydrate and go
actively the other way is not the best
strategy for performance ok
however the people that do go patio even
if they are say they're eating a
baseline of 2,000 Cal's paleo be in
2,000 cars they'll get more from nuts
seeds yeah
which isn't the fuel source you're gonna
use in the gym hmm you're gonna come in
you're gonna do some high intensity
training make you a five-minute arm wrap
you're probably not gonna use fatty
acids that much in a five-minute arm
wrap so can you explain let's say that
someone is thinking okay so that sounds
like me I do some normal push but like
bodybuilding stuff like I do CrossFit or
I do you know I play football which
again is you know we're talking about
that time domain that kind of like one
hour's work ish time domain maybe a
little bit more one hour work but when
you look up football yeah it's it's
interval training brief intervals of
sprinting you're recovering then you
sprint yeah in you're recovering then
you sprint when he's sprinting what you
do using carbohydrates to fuel right
you gonna glycolytic I guess bike in
your heart rate okay
so yet again you'll need carbohydrate
and often with elite teams of low
carbohydrate before the Lord
carbohydrate in half I'm Lord
carbohydrate post
I've always wondered this are you able
like having intra workout carbs yes your
body able to absorb that with like
sufficient speed for it to matter well
yes how long do you take to hit your
stomach it must be 20 minutes Dave your
stomach surely but then again if you're
training for an hour
mmm 20 minutes is fun yeah okay if you
look at it that way no no I totally get
it I just we always recommend I've got
no god off piece but it'd be good to
talk about it
timings and nutrition especially for the
spot performance so we categorize it in
several windows you've got your pre and
that'll be maybe you know talking
competition day although this
competition this is just specific days
like where for the active yes this could
be tomorrow yes so I don't know when
this videos going out but over 19.3 will
be tomorrow yeah and it will be what you
guess
oh god all right in the spot I think
19.3 might be something like
snatches yep bar muscle-ups cool and
maybe some lunges so like an ascending
like an ascending ladder of snapchat
with bar muscle-ups and lunges so kind
of similar to was it what was the web
lunges with the dumbbell yes lunges are
dumbbell cleans and it was dating I
think it was 18
no this is 17 to 18 to anyway something
like that what do you think it's gonna
be I hope it is more upper-body focus
because my legs have been crushed and
over the last couple of weeks you can
14th in the
fifteen minutes look let's not give it
to you but if you were to do placing
versus height yeah you're number one I
don't know
placing per inch of height I bet that
you're number one reps per inch of
height definitely timber I'm probably
body weight as well if you look at 80
kilos five foot eight yeah nearly ten
rounds small carves the small cars let's
tweak this streamline it stream like
someone someone's woken up in the
morning they're gonna train at midday
yeah what what they do so we're gonna
look at this window that we're gonna
create so it's gonna be pre that's gonna
be two one at one hour to our pre your
training we're gonna have a supply of
carbohydrate he's gonna complex sauces
so with carbohydrate is complex which
are the slower release and the simple
which is quick release okay that sugars
fruits so we'll have a blend of both so
say for example lots of oats a little
bit manner then we'll look at the next
macronutrient which is going to be
protein you're gonna have probably 2030
grams of protein regardless of height
weight gender so on so that could be a
scoop of protein in your oats that's got
a super simple here well want a little
bit of [ __ ] default ranges for energy
just for general caloric value leaving
in a training session so let's go a
scoop of peanut butter
yeah so in that the probably 400 Cal's
who got decent meal which is gonna fill
us before we go then we're gonna look at
the immediate pre so we want to load a
little bit sugars here this is just a
spiky guy could you be talking half an
hour before this is immediately pre so
this is you as you as you walk in and
this is all I'm walking into the gym
just have a banana right half 20 grams
of sugar with a banana yep then you're
gonna move on to intra window I'd say
this is kind of optional yeah like
especially further members a total idiot
you can do this you can't do this it
does you will see a decent exchange for
this like you will see a difference in
your energy okay and that'll be a liquid
carbohydrate muscle dextran decks rows
whatever you want here and other babies
just
it'll break down and you're talking
about just grazing on that or sipping
nuts how do you stick that throughout
your session especially through strength
training yeah
so I wouldn't recommend doing it through
your metcon you might do get a coach
like me they would just shout at you fat
when you drink yeah you are right even
though you're saying like Tommy John
online if you told me I have an inch or
workout but in the class you same pick
the [ __ ] bar exactly so in terms of
volume okay
in terms of amounts of carbohydrates so
we'll probably want about thirty grams
of sugar here okay ten grams of BCAAs
okay
during this intro work out period then
we're gonna move on to our pulse period
again there's gonna be two sections
we're gonna have our media post yeah a
little bit of protein just to assist for
cover it yeah quite a substantial amount
of liquid carbohydrates or sugars is
next runner guns yeah again this is just
for two reasons this this is for
immunity so if you know it's armed with
Olympians when they run their like
qualifying races it can't blend with the
crowd straightaway they need a little
bit of sugar because their glycogen
stores are depleted so then have a bit
of sugar top the carbs up then we'll go
for the interview mmm you'll see that
quite a lot with a lot of different
sports
let's intro so that's when you
susceptible to illness need to be after
you've just done a workout or yeah just
rigorous so if someone comes in cuffs on
me yep just after I finished what I've
got nice nice deflection in the phone
exactly right so we'll have a little bit
carbohydrate then we'll also want to
replenish our glycogen stores our muscle
glycogen stores
okay say if you don't an hour and a half
session yep you've had a lot of muscle
breakdown or fatigue that's when we want
to replenish then you'll have that with
you you'll slip it straight away you'll
go home have you meal try and limit your
fats in the meal we'll have a lot of
complex carbohydrate why we limit in our
thoughts in the male [ __ ] can you slow
down the absorption of carbohydrates
okay so you've got a pretty big window
around pre intra and post racing stretch
like four maybe five hours yeah you've
got a big big old window of their way
you're actually limiting fats right so
Eunice you have to focus your fats in it
was smaller when your that's further
away you can have any fats in the pre
one you can have a couple of scoops of
peanut butter or you have 20 20 grams of
fine general mm-hm
but I always recommend having knocking
out quite a lot of fats in the morning
yep and just sporadically pace these
three meals but I news fight your meats
in general the more nutrient dense like
chicken thighs and so on okay yes just
so you can get more bang for your buck
and be a little bit more strategic with
it you got a better range your macros
coming in from basically the same Smart
Balance I gather policies it's almost
like the zone approach when you look at
a meal it should be zoned with your
macronutrients mm-hm
we also try and use that to just balance
just have balance in your meals
especially when you're prepping you look
for a carbohydrate you look for your fat
look for you protein the few veggies and
you got a meal solder but suppose that's
the very analytic way to just look at
the plate right he's a major play it's
made up of all of these individual
things but people just see it as this
homogeneous food yes that's actually you
need to see why on what what is this
consisting and that's a very eye-opening
approach where a bed is sure even just
analyzing especially blasts or two and a
half years since I've been doing
Crossfit yeah and since I've considered
eating for performance a priority over
eating for aesthetics the IQ a it's a
big shift and there'll be a lot of
people who I think the vast majority of
people who know or who understand how to
diet or understand what their diet
should consist of will understand what
it is in order to lose fat yes like
people know that probably restricting
your calories overall there's a good bit
of bro science about like bro you wanna
you want to have a bit less carbs and
you want to all be a routine and stuff
like that I think people understand that
but again for me it was so eye-opening
starting to do CrossFit and realizing
hang on if I use performance as the
canary in the coalmine for how well my
diet is going
yeah and all that I do is eat to affect
my performance as long as my performance
is going up and I don't look like it
like a total slob in the mirror
I've probably got this pretty right yeah
you just need to find the balance with
this yes okay obviously when you
continue four or five six hundred grams
of carbohydrate like a lot of literature
suggests for sport performance you need
to be on six seven hundred grams of
carbohydrate yeah but that's not really
attainable in water people lives like
most people aren't these elite athletes
the video Gardein will be able to make
an image of Brent fikowski from I think
it was last year actually when he posted
something up on his nutritionist didn't
he reposted it on his instagram where he
had the 2017 games and he was on maybe
like five to seven hundred grams
yeah and then inside the 2018 games news
on like eight to nine hundred grams of
carbs a day I take that with a pinch of
salt I think what he may have not said
is that might be as comprar what's
exactly like what they consume that much
just the sheer volume of food must be
outrageous like I've got several kinds
on four or five hundred grams of
carbohydrate and coaching them through
that is challenging challenging because
I don't personally that so I've got to
be strategic how we get them there yeah
and the ease through that workout
nutrition it is crazy though to see
these guys like these top-level athletes
like Bret and you know he looks
fantastic you look and even more peeled
even fuller like a pro face performance
was fantastic like he's kind of he's an
endurance guy as well right like he's a
banker swimmer and he's got that kind of
long lean being look as well yeah so to
see someone put that much food away I
guess it'll probably be quite toss that
when you look at him you'll be maybe six
to sixty something like that or dude so
if you brought him down to the CrossFit
height yeah he'd be one most Jeff blokes
and again thought about by miles yeah if
you shrunk his if he done baby this he'd
be done lately without people soonish
huge so here's I think approach to each
other this got a little tangent
he arm was working a lot more restricted
stuff since he's a little bit heavier
yeah it's got longer leavers yeah so he
was working like it's try
setting lockout for his handstand
push-ups things like that he's got a
further range to go and so he was doing
a lot more strict work I think leading
up to the last games so that needs to be
seen a lot earlier by the extra
carbohydrates you think yeah that's
interesting one thing as well for anyone
who is listening that hasn't used Martha
dextran or dextrose in their shakes it
is it's just free money like it's the
same as Sonny Webster said have you ever
used a lifting belt or new knee wraps
had a sleeves I was like no I've never
use either any exact man it's just free
games yeah it's like both of those
things are just free games and for me
yeah you're going up you're stretching
the other one stretch to get it in boy
I'm tall you're gonna be so loose in
there Lunas after this so I'm yeah and
he says it's free games yeah like and it
seems to me mother dextran in a
post-workout shake and like especially
if you're struggling to hit your macros
I can't get them in yeah you won't even
feel it like a big scoop of any
maltodextrin in a post-workout shape
with two scoops of protein and a scoop
of creatine and in the space of three
minutes two minutes yeah you're like
I've done so much stuff yeah and I guess
that's the same as the the equivalent
for macros of the creatine as your
veggie shake in the morning right yeah
for sure then if you break that down a
little bit more your pledge and your
creatine stores that you've just
depleted with your creatine phosphate
okay so through ATP work through your
lifting yes like the explosive work
that's your one rep maxes and things
like that
you're replenishing your creatine levels
but that can also be done through right
meet some fishes some nuts but having
the creatine monohydrate will directly
affect would that be similar for if
you've got um someone who's doing a
maybe a rower like a competitive rowing
that's doing some interval work like
really hard like a 500 meter test or a
2k test or yeah stuff like that exactly
exactly same energy system so it doesn't
any matter about load it's about like
effort it's all about effort energy
system okay so if you look at he's doing
a fight he's doing a 2k
he'd be probably looking not for us but
he'd be probably looking at what like
five minute window yeah collecting that
takes up okay
so he'd fuel up when his carbohydrates
before make sure he doesn't deplete
during this session because you do talk
yeah I mean while you wrong it's very
difficult tough intro workout stuff oh
woodles one hand yeah I guess that's
what you'll be doing on the road though
that is what's - so you will remember
episode number one rowing the Atlantic
solo with ste Martin he's actually going
in would be like seven months now at the
end of the year I was too sure when the
day is but he's I'll be here an offer
it's still a big boy man he's have to be
a big boy for a long time now as well as
name yeah and there's been perma bulking
for two years
yeah he he's have to eat for his
performance though he's yet to eat for
the role so like I was saying about the
ketogenesis kind of vibe he will use his
body fat and body stores as his fuel as
heroes yeah because naturally as you
roll he's planning a two hours on two
hours off for a month you're probably
not gonna balance that energy through
food so you're gonna have to use
yourself the several role is when the do
when have came back they're just almost
half the man the way the set our ass he
was saying that it's between 35 and 70
pounds that he's expecting him to lose
on the duration of rowing across the
Atlantic and like one of the things that
[ __ ] blows me away is the fact that
Russ entually made back more jacked
after having swam around the UK like the
only difference is the fact that you had
salt Tong in like some ulcers yeah like
that was it it's mad he's a big did you
have a look at what he was eating and
stuff I saw a little bit I saw as I
listened to this Joe Rogan yeah it was
so neat a crazy inordinate amount with
bananas he was eating granola there's a
thousands of Bernard he's just looking
at macro again macro nutrient dense food
you've got to get your granola this
[ __ ] in there there's a lot of
carbohydrate in there it's quite it's
quite easy to eat as well yeah if you
ever you've ever poured 50 grams which
is one portion yeah of corner holla in a
bowl
you look at it like a sad lonely GIS
don't you're like what is this awesome
awfully so then you take your bowl off
the scale continue scaling one side no
one knows anymore
hopefully that camera didn't catch
anything what we've just done I totally
get it
so yeah I mean there's the rust actually
thing man he's a [ __ ] animal
I'm glad to see his eyes show okay so
he's I'm thinner I have no idea he's
doing a live show where he'll be doing
experiments live on stage and talking
about the swim and it's kind of a I
think the world's fittest tour will be a
live version of his book which is
bringing pretty interesting yeah coming
Jordan mark and them Phil one of my
buddies okay so I'm pretty excited to
put yeah it'll be he'll be interested
the podcast if you haven't already heard
it the podcast with Joe Rogan's [ __ ]
fascinating I always told you no matter
if swimming he was swimming and he kept
on getting um did jellyfish like he kept
on getting - yes he's swimming along for
ages and he was shouting to the captain
that he was in loads of pain and
couldn't work out why and the captain
was like no we can't take you back on
board at the moment you gotta keep
swimming yeah and he was like the pain
was just so bad I couldn't work out why
and he's got back on - you three are
yeah he kept on swimming for three hours
got back onto the boat and the reason it
turned out this jellyfish thing it's
been so bad was because it had wrapped
itself around his goggles and then
basically attached himself yet itself to
his face you had to like peel it off
yeah and then when his next
swim session was jus you had to punch
the goggles into his old like swollen
eye yeah that - bill - something else
it's got some great stories on there but
he brings up some CrossFit vibes which
aren't factually correct
lots of another star yeah that's a
better look for a different player
so we've we've talked about the fact
that foot training carbohydrates are
important I think that's definitely a
big takeaway that you need to be looking
at greens and you need to be varying as
I aspire your micronutrient ranges okay
what about if we move on to competition
so should people change the way that
they eat up to a competition and if so
why and if not why yes
so we
would change what we're eating so we
want to eat as efficiently as possible
so we're going to limit any inflammation
so as you're sat there you're eyeing up
a pizza it's only one day your
competitions on the Saturday is probably
not the best idea why you're probably
gonna get quite a lot of good
information from the gluten from the
gluten from everything in the food it's
not probably your typical food sauce
what foods are pretty easy to digest you
want to kind of look after you cook the
best you can in the lead up to try any
as normally as possible do you mean it
eating the same thing that your body's
used to eat oh yes okay what are these
real foods yeah eat balanced foods keep
smashing your micros in and from there
from the Monday see competitions on this
Saturday Sunday okay well I'm gonna
guess I'm gonna guess too soon ejector
that this would be pretty similar for
whether you're powerlifting presuming
you don't have to cut to meet wait no
whether you're gonna do from
powerlifting up to marathon yes yes so
we've got got several cyclists who with
wdn several triathletes will do exactly
the same protocol okay good carbohydrate
loading yes
so we'll keep fats and proteins
consistent yep I will just ramped up the
carbohydrates towards workout one or
this start line okay so rollers folder
on Monday we've avoided the pizza
someone's down low so yeah why don't you
the Dodgers ate so yeah so when they
will start from your base line of
carbohydrate will start ramping up
slowly depending on what your sport is
depending on who you are depending on
your intensity of the weekend depending
on how many workouts you have yeah and
so on and your gender as well we'll
probably rump guys a little bit quicker
than girls
then we'll spike them both towards the
end that's for no particular reason to
be honest we just guys can tolerate a
little bit more they've got more muscle
months yeah they can stop if my glycogen
and so on yeah so from there we'll just
start ramping up each day it'll almost
be a step there be a step of more
carbohydrate let me know anyway I'd lend
you an idea of the percentage so if you
were having a hundred percent was what
you would have on your baseline yeah
what are you doing on the Monday the
cheezer's
so instead of percent let's say we'll
add
they'd probably be the same to say the
same yeah Wednesday we'll probably add
50 to 75 grams of carbohydrate okay
Thursday we about 100 yeah Friday I'll
be 150 then over the competition weekend
we're gonna again try and eat as
efficiently as we can we're gonna stay
to our normal foods we're not gonna
overly spike our insulin to much as in
if you have I've ever been to accomplish
you see people smoking in sugars your
left right and center yeah you do you
need a little bit of sugar but try to be
smart how you eat one why is it about
intersection because you want to use
your sugar wisely you want to use your
sugar pre-post intra obviously there's
not gonna be that big four-hour window
that we used to in our training but
people are the heck it's smashing and
wine goes left right and center yeah and
yeah it was a little bit me at
strengthen depth but y'all he have a
little bit in front yeah and they're
from that just eat as normally as you
can look at hard maybe 250 extra grams
of carbohydrate on top of what you
ignore me Perconte Perconte okay so
really each comp day the wouldn't you
want to go 500 on the next day yeah yeah
yeah sorry so yeah the to prepare in
mind these people that are ramping up
towards the king competition they're
hundred percent is probably gonna be
quite a lot of carbohydrate 350 already
maybe more maybe a little bit more maybe
400 yeah depending 500 maybe so what's
cool is he said so we we do change our
diet in terms of the macro nutrient
again we don't change our diet in terms
of the food that we eat yes we just see
a little bit more okay cool so when you
say efficient eating efficiently what
you mean
so that's just using quite a wholesome
foods drink dense foods so you're gonna
use something like sweet potatoes you're
gonna use quite a little Rice's you're
gonna use chicken thighs chicken breasts
you're gonna eat not seeds quite what
you'd say healthy foods okay
wholesome foods why is that why are they
efficient so they're not gonna reduce
we're not gonna produce any inflammation
on you go so if you look into something
which is probably be gonna another
conversation will have is gonna be the
fodmap I want to go into this yeah so
eating her fodmap approach would be to
limit you're going from
so there's a lot of foods which spike
inflammation in your cup which is tricky
to digest and we all have a little bit
of intolerance to some foods the key
ones are like people always say gluten
yeah there is a little bit of underlying
in that like people aslam it and slam it
and slam it
yeah but there is if you don't feel 100%
one eat your food don't eat the food
yeah it's it's pretty it's pretty simple
yeah regardless if there's somebody on
TV or in suger I'm saying it's a myth
yeah if you feel pretty [ __ ] when you've
eaten something no probably don't you
like I am allergic to dairy there's a
lot of research which says have a
milkshake post-workout it's good for
recovery which that's true not for you
if I have that I got a swollen neck so
it's not all one size fits all approach
my recovery through the right there
cometh brilliantly yes I can get my neck
to go down exactly shirts and attire yet
running so um talk us through the fodmap
diet a little bit more
so the fodmap diet was what's fodmap so
good question okay I don't know thought
my head legal that is for the heart of
the map fodmap it's just explaining it
to me it's not telling me what it's
there you go there you go it is
fermentable oligo die mono saccharides
and have poly osis oh and Polly's videos
follow Polly's polysaccharides whatever
that thing it's that it doesn't you
don't need to know what it is you don't
it doesn't matter that it doesn't mean
anything not it's the same with
everything we do the abbreviation for a
reason you don't want to say that full
sentence I didn't remember what I was
reading it and I couldn't yes so so
basically if you get that back up I know
people can't see what it is yeah who's
the guy that puts things on our videos
Dean video guy Dean Dean videos will
make it appear here what's the chart
that you want so just click on any one
of these okay cool
[Music]
they'll be seamless cook yeah he's a
writer so so if we look here obviously
the chart was somewhere low fodmap at
high five map we will just basically
want to limit the - map foods in our
diet that does cause inflammation in
there got when we saved the girl that's
all about digestion okay and metabolism
so if you are constantly inflamed and
you got your digestion it's gonna be a
little bit off not gonna metabolize your
food all that well and I'm not that
research in the gut brain connection but
yes there is a massive link between how
efficient your gut is to your health in
your brain there's a fairly well cited
study that talks about the fact that
there's more neurotransmitter receptors
or there's more mood receptors in your
gut than around your brain yes so your
mood is determined more heavily by your
gut to a degree that gets fed back up to
you Brett yes um that your mood is
heavily determined by what you eat aside
yeah this bit maybe cut out I don't know
but my brother does research and got
enzymes okay and he's currently looking
into if there's like an enzyme in the
gut which does lead to diabetes okay
ah he is going to resit I don't know
it's not his current one that he's on at
the moment but he's gonna move to that
on the future and see if there's it got
enzyme you could introduce to people
with type 1 diabetes offset it to really
introduce this goes well above me yeah
but um to see if there's a big
connection and not seems like the risk
so that's pretty cool yes so all stems
from the gut he'll happy good happy you
what we're saying is that fun mark
appears to be a low resolution kind of
blanket coverage approach to just
ensuring that you're not gonna have an
upset stomach basically and they're
gonna reduce inflammation would
inflammation occur outside like in the
body as well as in the joints as well it
made you slow down your Energy's gonna
be a little bit lower
I'd recommend people to just limit the
weep limit the dairy and see where we
lives on good places there's two really
good places so that chart might appear
again
yeah the there's really common ones
apples are on their milk if we look down
legumes
yeah the things is full of legumes which
your favorite looking good fan of piece
of rice and peas month there's a little
of peas rice and peas is good it's a
debate about peanuts peanuts and legumes
only I don't really like the term leggy
legume sounds very Americanized it feel
like I feel like we didn't have a word
for the shoes you [ __ ] on peanuts
you're okay on okay low fodmap but
incredible CEOs aren't dark chocolates
okay hi Jose concert this is bad time
this year Americans isn't this is built
for Americans sugar-free confectionery
mmm
sometimes it's all basically hi Padma
foods are all the fun foods they are the
good ones
there's no biscuits in that yeah but I'm
sure there's a nice alternative biscuits
and snack products I mean snack products
covers if if [ __ ] saw rings in there
then following up what's the ingredients
sorry magic and imagine God dust
Unicom yeah exactly - unicorn tears of
banana unicorn exactly so I think the
fodmap thing so you mentioned it to me
in the gym you today yes it is quite
interesting and I definitely have
noticed since I've cycled off taking
milk her having almond milk that can I
don't enjoy the taste quite as much I'm
still shopping around for the one that I
prefer weirdly enough I'd have thought
the sweetened one would have been well
nicer but it's not no it's a very very
doesn't it's just like yaks my face turn
inside out so athletes who are looking
at potentially changing through some
foods fodmap will be linked in the show
notes below have a little looking did
you advise to do it incrementally so to
take each fodmap thing out one by one
though you can identify it it'd be an
elimination approach so if you're in
your current diet you're getting a lot
of inflammation you get an upset good
your bowel movements aren't great not
great topic to talk about I just start
to slowly eliminate foods go over two
three four week cycle yeah so if you
stop just by cutting out milk or limit
dairy or linear yogurt
and introduce it and if it's back yeah
take it out again and then okay now
that's either stayed or gone then wheats
gonna stay or go then yeah and it's
slowly refining your few choices not
that does take a while and it means it
is trial and error and you can get a
food allergy chart and that might might
see a little bit better but you want to
eat the best you can for you everybody's
a little bit different so if you eat the
best you can the way you feel great
that's basically what we want if you
feel great
he cuts probably doing well hmm I think
the man thing about that is it would
appear if you had a adverse reaction to
some of the stuff that's on Pharma
really regardless of whether it's the
middle of winter it's Christmas Day it's
the day before a competition you
mid-workout yeah those foods really but
unless you're making a concerted
exception because you really want to
have it for either like situation or
taste or whatever it might be those
foods shouldn't ever appear in your diet
yet whey protein though whey protein
what I've done the same I've told you
minus 1 J on the beef hydrolyzed beef
from my protein what do you think it's a
protein sponsor before there so the
protein works actually today go on the
guys the guys know that they they used
to have a beef derived protein they're
currently developing a new one so right
now my best advice is actually bulk
powders so I've tried bulk powders on my
protein the reason that I like both how
does beef protein is it isolate so that
my protein 1 is thick as isn't thick as
[ __ ] so like I have to punch it down
yeah down my neck like which is
difficult thank you when you've got your
mastered x-ray shake I don't at the
moment what he thought was to add that
in like it would be probably almost
undrinkable like it's crazy thick which
is actually the mom because I'm dieting
is actually quite nice and a lot more
satiating yeah when it comes to me
trying to get those calories in I would
certainly be switching across bulk
powders do this they do too but the one
that you want is the
beef I select how the [ __ ] that moniker
I've currently got this
I mean I've currently got a protein yeah
the chocolate one yes good it's good it
is good lot thinner a lot thinner but um
so let's go back around yes you're dying
okay let's let's run through this me
dieting let's run through this so in
terms of you die thing what's your
approach to dying just because style
calls back it sounds like so have you
understood your tdee or your metabolic
baseline as we we'd suggest so as you
found out what about is are you using
I'm using what with so some of the
listeners will know that I've been
wearing to work swoop strapped for the
last six months or so it's an always on
heart rate tracker activity tracker
workout tracker resting heart rate HIV
which is your heart rate variability
sleep tracker and a few other things as
well once you've taken account
thermoregulation in heat loss no so it's
easy it's a blood instrument of working
out how much energy you've expended
throughout the day but it's a lot easier
or a lot better in my opinion than just
I'm picking the number that your weight
is and hoping for the best and then yeah
all I worked out a bit today yeah you
can't that's a nutrition code there you
go link will be too will be a nutrition
in the show notes but I have a joke by
the way
no genuinely will be so yeah in terms of
me dieting it's just reducing calories
like what's your approach to that like a
you prioritizing your workout nutrition
so you keeping the focus on you're gonna
head in the gym and keep a hundred
percent in your training sessions no so
given my you just kind of I usually got
a blanket approach that I'm just gonna
drop down I'm probably gonna get my
workouts don't earlier on in the day so
I feel a little bit better here given
that I said I've focused on eating for
performance this now seems a little bit
like I'm only a hypocrite but my point
is that right now I don't have time it's
two weeks until I go away from WOD like
I don't have time to be focusing on
performance the way that I'm actually
doing it is mixing together intermittent
fasting okay with
just basically locales so I'm staying
fasted until about 2:00 in the afternoon
wow I tend to Train it about 9:00 or
10:00 in the morning so I'm training
fasted I'm aware that goes against Al
I've spoken about today but I do have to
say that training fasted on the morning
is the best time that I can get that in
like if I was dieting I would much
sooner train as soon as oh yeah
definitely could you wake up you feel a
little bit good you have a little bit
caffeine yeah and I more what energy
does I die it's almost like I get the
training session in before my body
realizes it's hard time to realize that
hungry
if you're and by the time I finished
like that sir finished at eleven eleven
half eleven no the caffeine I'm tending
to have a post-workout shake it also
will have some stuff in there afterwards
then by the time it gets to like get
home 32 p.m. go I saw it I saw it out
and I'm like okay what's time to eat yes
so I'm actually doing a podcast with
David Sinclair who was on Joe Rogan he's
one of the world's leading longevity
experts works out with Harvard
University yes so I'm going the students
pocket
okay I'm going to Harvard to sit down
with him write accounts before I go and
see inside tracker
so I'll be very interested to kind of
chase up some of the points that he had
about intermittent fasting word yes on
that podcast book if you haven't
listened to it already it's it's really
interesting and if you've ever
considered going to start doing
intermittent fasting like he sells the
dream mmm so [ __ ] hard in there and
it's just through data like he's not
saying it's amazing and this is I do it
and you should do it because of these
reasons
he's just presenting what the data seems
to show no maybe let me turn this around
a little bit so I have two approaches to
inner they're fasting okay the first one
is if you're in a severe caloric deficit
obviously I wouldn't suggest going too
deep in the caloric deficit yeah but if
you are yeah fine I'd probably recommend
to do intermittent fasting so you bring
your eating wing window down so you can
eat pretty regularly from 2:00 p.m.
until 10 p.m. 10 p.m. I saw and you
don't really see the effects of your
shortened calories then the second
approach is from like an athlete's
approach a performance approach if you
do in a min fast so you've your last
meal was
or lasting UA is 10 p.m. you go through
who write to your training session at 9
a.m. the morning so you're pretty much
working on empty at the time so your
session is gonna be diminished by a fair
few percent you'll have less to give
your cover is going to be down community
is going to be down you go into your
sector yeah you have a bit of protein
afterwards we still haven't replenish
your glycogen stores yet
so you're probably going to be very
vulnerable to infection or getting ill
exactly what you need before holiday
yeah and yeah yeah you go back into
Windows so as somebody say if you were
trying to get the most out of every
training session I'd recommend thrown a
little bit of workout nutrition around
your sessions yes then just focusing on
having as many veggies and much
satiation through food as possible okay
so eating a lot of volume of spinach of
yeah and so on and try and keep your
protein fairly high inconsistent that's
not really gonna do much it
you're burning protein by eating it and
trying to digest it do you undo you ever
advocate diet for athletes who aren't
trying to cut down to a particular
weight category do you often advocate
deficit yes so what we always do with
every approach regardless what your goal
is not so much a performance company we
do have a lot of performance athletes
we've also got a lot of health athletes
our health our fleets and performance
athletes start the exact same approach
so we look at the micros we look at
their general health we look at
balancing their energy regardless what
the Spy's what their lifestyle is from
here generally if you are looking at
performance we'll start adding calories
and adding carbohydrates if you are just
looking at general body composition
we'll start taking away a little bit of
color ease and we'll just focus on
consistency over several months when I
say several months it might be two three
so on before we start to recon it back
to the baseline and let our metabolism
just chill for a while
mmm-hmm that's not so much with the
guys they can carry on going so if you
are looking at wanting to lose some way
or go into a little bit of a deficit I
just recommend going about 5 percent of
your total calls every week every 2
weeks and just see with constant
consistency where you can get take your
time with a try any within 10 grams of
your macronutrients and just slowly
plummet down
you shouldn't go too low to where it
should affect your performance it
definitely shouldn't affect your
cognition you should feel pretty good in
yourself you should just feel slow
consistent weight loss when I say weight
loss I hate saying that term you should
just take a lot of progress pictures
just have a visual in front of you yeah
there's a lot of factors that can
influence weight like the worse the
wants to kilo of variation on weight
daily and that's with water carbohydrate
timings hydration dehydration
inflammation you have to make sure from
training our measurement of food bowel
movements I'm just general just
fluctuations yeah so there's always a
lot of people that do just focus on that
number on the scales and a lot of the
time you can just go on the scales jump
off the scales go on the scales jump off
the skin if you do that four or five
times probably lost a little bit of
weight yeah I might go up you know you
never know yeah but with that there'll
always be a little bit of fluctuation to
take your weight with a big pinch of
salt just have a visual of what you want
to do and where you want to go have a
strong goal in mind you know have that
visual of your progress picture do you
don't need to share it around like we
rarely post progress pictures and that's
fine like that's we will obviously if
there is some available to post but we
don't want to use that as a marketing
strategy you want to just keep those for
you you keep those for you feeling good
that should always be the fact that we
focus on I think one of the things that
a lot of people struggle with and this
is why increasingly I'm seeing people
talk about the negative mindset that
comes along with bodybuilding and
fitness and fitness training overall yep
typical growth in Australia
not Fitness for CrossFit which is that
your progress is externalized especially
if you're competing it's externalized to
someone who isn't you yeah but even if
you aren't competing it's externalized
to your own mindset you could wake up in
a month's time 1% leaner
yeah the kilo heavier than you are now
but if you're in a really [ __ ] space
you're in a bad mindset you look in the
mirror and you're like look crap I'm not
happy with the way that I look I mean
like what hang on by every objective
measure you've managed to get yourself
in better Nik
yeah and you've got to remember those
goals but was he goal to begin with the
Kreutz body [ __ ] only increase what
happens in once a month so you submit
now you've crushed that yeah but just
because your mindset is not an objective
measure and then obviously like you say
people trying to externalize that to go
okay well I'll just focus on the scales
yes well it kind of needs to probably be
somewhere in between if over the course
of two months your weight has been
steadily increasing and you're supposed
to be in a deficit yes we need to make
some adjustments yeah however if that's
happened and you've got like visible ab
veins you know you're doing something
right maybe you're training super hard
yes maybe you know chief looks theory
I'm aware is kind of criticized but it
is kind of a thing that sometimes gets
cited usage made a really [ __ ] good
point the other day said people think
that they don't have a bodybuilding goal
as I guess they're wrong it's just a
matter of perspective everybody has a
bodybuilding gone that's just that some
some people's change but everybody wants
to be a bit leaner you had a bit bigger
yes like in terms of muscle mass every
every male anyway yeah every cross
better everything cross every CrossFit
for sure but I think even females like
if you gave them the choice and like
most females would be like yeah I could
do with you know two having maybe a
little bit more shape to my legs on my
carbs on my shoulders on the back I'm a
bit like ABS I'm or whatever and I could
do with being a little bit leaner like
even [ __ ] the girls that are the most
comfortable with in their own body would
still say oh well done mate if you just
said pick from this menu of options that
you alright you want here yeah exactly
I'll watch you I'm happy with my
leanness but I'd love to have slightly
bigger
whyever like boom or like not gonna be
done via training that's an addition so
I think we've got through them some
really cool stuff there I like the idea
the green shake in the morning is a good
take
way I think that the importance of carbs
in and around training for training um
one thing that way to check is there a
rough rule of thumb that people can use
to judge what their carbohydrate intake
should be based on their weight yes so
top of my head so it's between two grams
per kilo and I bought seven grams vicar
there's quite a lot of variation and it
pens on who you are what you do male
female
okay detraining history training
environment yeah how long you trained
for what you do for a lifestyle approach
so what you do for work that can really
affect how many carbohydrates you need
and these are all factors that you do
want to look into however that can be a
little bit of variation on one thing I
didn't want to get into when we're
talking about different sports we've got
quite a lot of weight lifters with EE
the end and we've got a slightly
different approach to a lot of weight
lifters and it it's quite conflicting I
think we're lucky that our wait list is
also competing CrossFit so their target
weight they're going to compete up isn't
ridiculously low like it is with a lot
be able to do MMA I need to see like
severely cook so we always want to see
what your long term goal is so if mine
was to compete
75 kilos I don't even know if that's
category I'd look at in six months time
how can I slowly get to 75 kilos
maybe 76 77 kilos before the event we
want to perform at a hundred percent and
not completing up to for the weeks
completing opti up pretty much your
stage weight then the day before we
might strict a little bit of war on my
cheese and gum we might drop the salts
and so on blow it up on the salts on the
day and get you guys up that way then
rather than all your competition it's
gonna be sweet dehydrated they're gonna
look like [ __ ] on the day they're gonna
be shaking on the scales then they're
gonna have this feely rehydrate worth
turning up
we know our maxes we hit them earlier in
the week we're turning up
represent we're fueled we're ready to go
so we've got slightly different approach
to up a few people half is that quite
contrary to what's typical yes
well I think like a leap weightlifting
they do want to go in as heavy as
possible and then go on as light as
possible
oh then yeah okay yeah having backup so
we we want to be out that wait a couple
of weeks before so we're performing a
hundred percent but that pretty much
stage way do you think that given the
balance between the two that there's
less stuff that can go wrong
yeah it's like the main reason we look
at it in terms of health so if you're
when you see a lot guys who do Emma made
the step on the scales and they're
pretty much gonna collapse it Maceo -
yeah they're emaciated I wouldn't see
that that person on the scales as like
an elite sportsmen or a picture of
health or a picture of health we want to
turn up healthy we don't wanna drop our
body severely out of homeostasis we want
to rock up feeling good knowing we're
gonna hit our maxes and turn off on the
day a hundred percent I think that's
definitely again you know to kind of
sing the praises of CrossFit to a degree
the fact that their own weight
categories yes it's such a beneficial
thing long-term for the health of the
people that are doing it I can say what
you want about the fact that it dangers
an injury for CrossFit and high
repetitions of heavy weights under
fatigue and all that sort of stuff but
no one's using diuretics before they go
and compete in CrossFit and like I
always use this example I used up first
have a podcast where I said that if you
look at especially in bodybuilding but
also to degree in powerlifting and
things like that a lot of people in the
build-up to their particular competition
in a sport of choice that isn't to
CrossFit will actually not look forward
to that comp racket so you'll see people
especially bodybuilding guys everyone
will have someone who's done a fitness
show or a bodybuilding show on their
Facebook and they'll say now begin to
start a 16-week cook like it's gonna be
sat yet gonna be savage and like I'm
sorry if I'm not really gonna be
friendly and this and the other and
you're like I mean if you take the
period for CrossFitters which is
December until I guess February for the
open or they'll change now but yeah oh
yeah if you take any period movement
till a competition it's their favorite
time the training once or twice a day
they're loving the training everything's
going min everything's dialed in they're
eating like fog like they're getting to
eat logs they out get another fresh air
like it's I imagine it must be similar
for a lot of them a lot of guys that do
powerlifting that don't have to meet
wait yes like if you get to constantly
Pete like Rhett PB over and over and
over again it must be cool whereas again
you know like we said if you know as an
MMA athlete that you're going in and
you've got they you've got this week
looming over you yeah where you like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] like but worth for
those like that that dehydration effect
on your brain and your cognitive
approach then you're gonna go step in
the ring again it's almost like it's
almost a different a little bit out for
me yeah it's a different element at the
sport I think like I you can be the best
fighter in the world but let's say there
is something about your particular
genetic makeup over your particular
biome the biomechanics your biology air
which doesn't permit your body to
perform well when you've had to do that
dramatic way girl like you could be the
best fighter on the planet mm-hm
but if that's the case like you fight
yeah I think with that this should be
like an agreement to save where we would
fight it the same way let's just fight
the same way you know what I mean like
these weight categories the the savage
to get there like and especially when
somebody's trying to drop down from a
weight division to another weight
division yeah you've seen it quite a lot
that was I think guy called Dylan Shaw
so he he crushed a lot of people and he
dropped down for a drop down for a fight
and he was not there he was one of the
leanest people I've ever seen going in
the fight our veins everywhere TJ
Dillashaw some good doing good Nick I'm
really I think the this talk with the
UFC about them having
intra wait tests over period leading up
to the fight and then I'm only being
allowed to drop particular percentages
which restores our restricts the damage
and it's a health the healthiest thing
right yeah
so yeah we've got our green shakes we've
got the importance of carbohydrates we
know that we've got a range of two to
seven grams I'm gonna guess for most
people it'll be between three and like
three and five something like that three
and five grams per kilo of body weight
is what you want to be hitting we want
to bunch it around our training we want
a bit of intro bit of BCAAs 10 grams of
BCAAs paragraphs 10 10 grams that's a
lot BC yogurt it was to scoops job a
recommendation of BCA is that you're
right let's just go with your protein
the Robbie works probably much to make
fantastic BCAAs don't know let's say
that they do there's a link in the show
notes below and finally what about stuff
before bed like this so we told a lot of
things you can take yeah just just like
bedtime digestion you know you can get
like casein overnight slow release
project is it all bollocks
this is it mostly bollocks it's it is
slow release a this thing for is it
Monday especially when you're having
potentially muscle breakdown in your
overnight fast think what you doing in
your sleep to get regular thing I do we
wanna know yeah I don't know you could
get some like your body will still need
a supply of fuel as you sleep so it
could be a good thing to have some
casein but if you look in a sleep
nutrition it that's more about getting
your is that amazing so the zinc
magnesium that'll really help the sleep
you can take things like that's another
one
5htp so obviously serotonin precursor
yep yeah serotonin if you're not in the
UK yeah no instead 5htp is a serotonin
precursor another serotonin you can't
buy it can you know you think I'm sure
there's some things here but yeah I'm
big advocate of Zedd amazed again using
them for a while
interestingly when I was tracking my
sleep I actually found sometimes that my
sleep quality worsened for a short
period when I started using them again
okay and apparently that's quite typical
like again it's just throwing off what
you've where you gotta sleep it is that
is there anything you is there a window
within which you wouldn't eat before you
go to sleep do you try and leave a gap
or do you not really care not massively
not myself I wouldn't load a lot of
sugar before you go up there
unless you really need the simple
carbohydrates before it immediately
before you go to sleep it's probably
going to play havoc on your sleep as
well if you she's foolish sugar and
you've got a boatload of energy unless
you want to ride that insulin crash if
you're having like an hour and a half
before you head and ride that into the
crash alright when you sleep love that
that's like the carbohydrate equivalent
of taking of having a spliff isn't it is
like I she sells like a baguette Haribo
yeah wait for an hour and a half getting
a warm bed over love this so any other
things that you think that people should
consider any final tips I like the green
smoothie thing I'm already sold on ok
let's have a look what we missed have
you missed any so we miss anything we've
talked about most of this on comp prep I
wrote down leading up to a competition
you'd probably want 7 to 12 grams of
carbohydrate per kilo of body weight
that is it's softer now usually my me
I'd be talking nearly a kilo of
carbohydrate unlike I'll be quite a lot
the day before but it would be a
significant amount if you want to
preview performance and go in there 100%
might be the way to do I'd obviously
that I'd be a sustained that would be
your first competition going a kilo of
carbohydrates before that I'd be yes
several kind of wall of events to get to
that level it's gonna say would you
recommend if someone is warming up for a
competition or something like that let's
say that someone's gonna go do a half
marathon or they're gonna go do anything
would you recommend like a test prep
like competition like I'd say so on that
I think people should be doing that from
a programming programming perspective
anyway so you should have mock comp
weekends
whether that's a team event you'll just
run through four or five workouts one
day for look out the next day I think
that's really good to learn a lot about
yourself a lot about how you approach
your work out a lot about how you need
to tactically spread your food
throughout the day when where you need
your food where you need your hydration
hydration plays a massive effect on a
comp day so we'll need you'll probably
put your baseline hydration at three
liters a day then you work out you're
probably gonna need to restore about one
to two liters of fluid loss so workout
per workout yeah oh my god so when I was
more that's more than I would have
thought I would have needed yes you're
looking at Foley is a day if you have
one hour workout yeah most people should
be consuming that anyway a lot of people
don't yeah and that will play havoc with
you recovery with a lot of cramps and
things like that especially with your
salt loss so some electrolytes could be
a great thing to throw in post-workout
so having electrolytes on your comp day
again that's an awesome idea yeah
especially as a crossfitter where you're
gonna sweat in your wall I'm gonna sweat
on the dance floor
you're gonna come off sweating yeah and
you're just gonna sit still there's a
recommendation for that you thinking
lucozade
die or alight like I've literally yet
there are a day or alike or just any
generic electrolyte that drinks yeah
like I used to recommend making your own
so like a pinch of Himalayan pink sea
salt yeah some wine some honey and a
liter of water let's mix that up pretty
much what it is yeah it give or take
this difference also there but yeah
that's kind of give or take that
basically what it is there is some so I
don't there's no [ __ ] minerals in that
I don't suffer tremendously bad with
cramps like it's not something is deep
it feels like something that was kind of
stopped in the 90s okay but you know no
one talked about cramp anymore yeah they
don't and the only time that I've ever
really had it was when I
out training white eye in Thailand yeah
and I was training maybe two hours a day
twice so four hours a day in the heat
sweating like fun and it was the first
day after our first double session we do
this before our training and the next
day I went in at my car what my car's
just yeah just turned into like a vise
and I'm one of the guys went oh you need
you need and waved this like sachet of
to they said she died or a light so I'm
sure enough I'm on and I was like oh I'm
gonna have one of these a day I've never
had it before but yet dehydration and
high Warnock's I was consuming enough
water yeah but it was diluting down the
amount of salt to hurt exactly but you
probably weren't continuing enough
Wapiti sweat loss levels my god we once
did a study when I was at uni so we did
we did some hypoxic training yep to see
the effects of sweat loss a weight water
weight loss compared to higher hypoxic
and non hypoxic hypoxic swell you're not
breathing right yeah we do our breathing
but less oxygen restricted breathing
restricted breathing that wasn't with
the masks you throw those away so to
have yeah it's in a oxygen chamber more
so - it's a very same thing it wasn't
just like breathe you with straw and
things yeah yeah it was uh in a chamber
so I think I lost four kilos in like a
40-minute bout of exercising in fluid so
that's four liters of water that's so
insane yeah so when you actually study
it may be more than a maybe more than
later but is that applicable to
everybody's life when you you are doing
a double day session and you work around
it maybe you're a teacher and you can't
learn you're free didn't you're on your
feet and you're trying to get four or
five liters of water in during the
evening of i-70 every 15 seconds which
you're probably not allowed to do you
know you've got it's a pretty Brian
you're already on each other with marker
pen yeah somebody's looking the window
and the car is looking a window and I
think so anything else anything else
that you think that is a little hack or
things that people should consider the
fodmap thing definitely I'm you know I'm
the perfect avatar for someone who
doesn't bother to like play around with
Dalia for me it's very transactional
like does it does it do what I needed to
do
kind of need them in there yeah yeah
whereas I'm slowly moving through hours
of your recommendation I'm slowly moving
through different food groups on the
fodmap scale and then getting rid of
them I'm looking forward to coming back
and not having a been a deficit anymore
so I can eat laugher a little bit more
kind of cleverly any other bits that you
think in terms of protein try and eat
between 1 to 2 grams of protein per kilo
of bodyweight maybe a little bit more
I'd say that'll be the recommendation
for pretty much everybody yeah
protein it's naturally satiating so a
big chunk of protein will keep you full
for quite a long time so I tend to push
your protein up a little bit more than
some guidelines just so and when you
digest your protein you increase your
energy consumption anyway so that
thermal effect of food is via the
protein so increase your protein and
that's what at the time fine don't go
too far through the roof don't take that
what I've just said and go let's eat 14
pounds of meat into the onion style do
the Atkins diet it'd be nice to talk
about fats for a while we talked about
funds yeah like like fads of nutrition
yeah well I mean what are the big ones
let's try to miss the big ones that we
can think of so what let's go what's
what's the worst or best part you've
ever done oh god when I think about fad
diets so for a long time I was doing
carb backloading I thought but ok maybe
7 years ago but I I hadn't read carb
backloading all that I'd done was
anecdotally heard that what it was so
you just put the carbohydrates to the my
carbohydrates at the end of the day but
like my carbohydrates my typical day
would be no carbs until training
training around about sort of 4 or 5
p.m.
yeah then have a 560 gram tub of
Sherwood's chicken korma sauce with
about 500 grams of chicken it with about
300 grams of uncooked rice and
then a birthday cake and a cake I don't
like it but like a birthday it wasn't my
birthday but I'd have a birthday cake
and I'd be like yeah cart backloading no
way no way don't look at it what you've
done is a restricted window of eating
yeah and say if you're eating with all
that food they're 3,000 calories that
could be exactly the same with having a
slice of cake throughout the day right
there throughout the day splitting that
meal up 2 to 3 portions that's the kind
of the premise what I look at with our
in the Moon Kingdom in fasting yeah that
you could get the same effect just by
eating
so I've done more bits throughout that
I've done that I did carb nite which is
a single night per week version of that
I did that like the 5 to kind of
approach no yes yes it is is the 5 to
approach so essentially carb nite is
carb backloading one then you
intermittent it throughout days over the
week rather than throughout like within
right itself so you'll have like three
days off one day on of carb backloading
then I did skip loading which is [ __ ]
Elvis the a popular Aida fruits right
into the [ __ ] bro science here
so skip loading was built for people
that we're doing bodybuilding comprar
mmm so it goes like it's essentially no
car goki tour through the week and then
you're on a Sunday you would eat as many
carbohydrates with nothing else so like
every feed yes but with knows how to
hydrate just jobs and the the seed have
no protein that they don't not well it
was just as a byproduct like it was
aimed solely in your broccoli yeah aim
the max when he was Napoli probably
nothing brought the idea and you're
right
and it was like the main thing that was
advocated was you need to start your day
by trying to get through a box of kids
cereal because kids serie will be low in
fat what would be the one like probably
Frosty's or honey nut cheerios they're
pretty that big way what do you know
what kind
oh look like me is lipid oh if it's if
it's peanut I'm alright but if it's
[ __ ] cashews so did that like it's a
skip loading that was mental because I
used to live next to a Waitrose in
judgment and the Waitrose I we always
knew that 3 p.m. closed up for 3 p.m.
are you gonna be markdowns all of the
bakery goods would be 9 pence so like
just go in spend like for quit in come
up with bags of yum Yum's
yeah and caramel doughnut and I just sit
there and just like go as hard as I
could
that was [ __ ] like I was asleep by 5
p.m. oh I was just crashing half in a
khole yeah I was how did you find that
I'm like what was your anecdotal
evidence ah oh it's just so CDC Oh so
for me that the worst thing about it was
or the worst thing about lot of these
diets are that they aren't sustainable
because you have this really harsh
sacrifice reward mentality and it's fair
enough that that's programmed in let's
say you're doing car backloading one of
the things I actually did quite like
about cutback thought it was it it
teaches you to have a sacrifice reward
mentality see right okay I'm gonna go
carb free for the majority of the day
that I'm going to reward myself with
carbs and then evening the time that
most people cheat is I mean evening yes
which meant actually in terms of how it
programs into your day and in your
mindset it wasn't that stupid and just
didn't have tremendously good effect yes
the skip loading was the same sorry
carb nite was the same but turned up a
little bit and then skip loading was the
same but turned up to once per week yeah
like keto I've tried loads of times but
I don't naturally eat a lot of that I
don't perform fantasy well I have late
nights like it's not for me I always
feel hungry as well like I just can't
stop myself feeling hungry on keto yeah
I'm the same and I've tried to go not a
full keto and paleo was a thing it might
be thinking CrossFit
yeah I've obviously tried to do failure
ah oh geez found just an abundant lack
of energy
later I found that was because I was the
Alexi eurocar lauric and an energy
deficit Oh without a doubt
booze deficits but most these farts are
just looking at a caloric deficit it's
you know for all the people don't want
to over generalize things like a lot of
these diets appear to work by the fact
that if you take your total calorie
expenditure there are seven day period
and just balance total calorie intake
sorry it's less than it would have been
the difference is could you achieve the
same degree of calorie deficit and or
weight loss with consistency in eating a
5 percent deficit of 10 years yeah
and with just less suffering yeah like
because this this suffering is the thing
that's the foremost like that the
results and all of that stuff a
secondary yeah but the most visceral
part of any diet is the way it makes you
feel yeah like if your diet actually
makes you feel ill more tired or grumpy
or you can't get an erection or you've
always shot with your kids you know that
all of these things are byproducts of
particular kinds of diets you're like if
that is what your diet is leaving you to
do you need to [ __ ] do a different
one
yeah so that's why it's certainly for me
to diet that I'm using at the moment is
literally just calorie restricting like
yeah it's done through intermittent
fasting but the only reason of the main
reason I'm doing that is just because
it's convenient mmm but if I don't need
to eat or cook until 1:00 p.m.
yeah I can do so [ __ ] much is a lot
you can do in that time really crack it
out like morning routines rapid training
yeah it'll suffer but for me I'm like
okay you can get through it what about
you if you didn't easily diet not that
many to be honest because you are a
nutritionist yeah so I've always kind of
apart from going paleo too stuck to the
evidence
yes stuck to the evidence looked at the
literature but I haven't looked at the
literature and tried to replicate with
me so I've tried to use beets or B treat
for performance right try and get that
was it the nitric oxide value of it so
it surveys or dilator you know so you
should have more blood flow
I love you everything that just read
right side the piss bread okay bowels
movements were completely read okay yeah
I didn't feel that good I was eating
about kilo be treatment day eating it
yeah so I liquidize their ID the e
beetroot cooked beetroot
how long have you do this for I tried to
do it for a full open across it
obviously naturally I started on the
Friday of the first open announcement
yeah I thought this is gonna be great
for my performance for weeks
pure Reds just we read everywhere I
wasn't feeling good
just that one basically I've tried tart
cherry for recovery have you didn't the
apple vinegar thing apple cider vinegar
yeah I've tried it I've got it wrong
every time I've tried to reintroduce it
so instead of dye you men to dilute it
aren't you the naked eye always the
first time I go back to forget to do
that so I'll do you like it like a
decent cop yeah try and get through as
my throat burning yeah its savage it is
savage but there is I think the whole
evidence of that and if it does make you
feel good
mmm persist with it if you get the the
Thibault effect off a lot of these
things it's another way that placebo
effects the most reliable effect in all
the pharmacology right like if there's
this awesome club on a podcast I listen
to recently said if we can bottle the
effect that the placebo effect have we
have a panacea that things is all
ailment yeah you know well yeah so if
you believe it hard enough so what we
really need to do is just tell people
sell them anything
yes make them believe it hard enough for
the kids sufficiently convincing story
that's what mom then it will work in
that is what marking and then we see a
lot of that unfortunately you see a lot
of people trying to do that and try and
market to either towards their product
which is one unsustainable so it's
severely clogged deficit or to the can't
fit into their lifestyle so like the
beauty about tracking macronutrients and
trying to optimize micronutrients is
that you can be a little bit flexible
every now and then you can stick to that
form up approach
percent at the time 20% at the time you
can have a donut you can have a treat
the kids you can have a treat with the
family you can't go out for a family
meal as long as you trying to balance
that energy consumption for each day off
setting the training and you either even
to perform your eating to perform us in
a deficit yeah so whilst we're doing
that what we're trying to optimize that
workout nutrition window and we're on a
winner I don't see another approach to
nutrition which has such a long term
benefit as optimizing your micros yeah
and macros at the same time it's very
robust it's very robust people obviously
take it to the next level with if if 50
macros approach which is just anything
else is if it fits your macros
is that not the essentially the same is
what you're saying but in discounting of
the micro yes
basically yeah and you might eat a
little bit too much sugar you might have
a lot of inflammation through food your
food might not agree with you all the
time but if you look at it from a
simplistic point of view and yeah every
now and then you can do if it fits your
macros and that's fine like that will
balance your energy on that day you've
got a offset that day look at optimizing
the micros for the rest of the week and
we can get there we can get there with
your goals I think it's it's so creative
deficit
it's so weird especially I'm gonna have
this conversation with yourself today
and and speaking to you in the build-up
to this over the last few weeks it is so
bizarre that there are so many different
routes to so many different approaches
that appear to have gained speed with
regards to successful diets yeah like if
you were to look at what we've spoken
about today which is that if you use
your performance and the way that your
mood and that you feel is as a litmus
test for how effective the foods that
you're eating are if you take foods
which are across the board well
researched as often causing some form of
discomfort whether that be information
or an intolerance or whatever it is
that's the farm app thing that we spoke
about
and then if you eat based on the the
micronutrient requirements the like year
three in school
you should eat five pieces of fruit and
vege a day and I should have a colorful
you should eat the meals that I've got
two or three or more colors and you're
like I think the problem with it is that
it's the least sexy oh that's so not
sexy like trying to say that filio Miley
Oh Sakura Alice all that stuff like
that's not the stuff that's proven by
science is often not sexy it's not
Glory's hmm you don't look at some
amazing pharmaceutical companies and go
yeah exactly
look at the lovely new vaccinations that
we've got that they're like but if
there's if there's a pill that works a
little bit but also gets you high at the
same time people will go straight to
that yeah but it's not gonna work
long-term
yeah I think certainly for me the and
this is coming from someone who's played
around with and the same as you like
anyone who's been in the industry of
fitness for a while is [ __ ] around
with dye and yes seen what works and
what doesn't work yeah and the best diet
for me too appears to be the one that I
can stick to the longest yes like if
it's something that's sustainable and
for some people they may actually have
their window of sacrifice and reward may
work over a day long period or a even a
couple of day long period where you
could go right okay low low high low low
high that might be their routine or
whatever it is and they're like if
that's you that's sweet but for me I
would much sooner wake up and know that
if it's a training day me in a bit more
if it's a rest day me in a bit less and
but I'm gonna follow a robust and varied
diet
yep we are for protester that we've got
a high day if you do an exhaustive
training we've got a moderate day which
is your typical training day I've got a
recovery day which might be a hike maybe
some mobility might be a walk it might
be the crews on the assault bike then
we've got a load a which is complete
rest and with that we're just looking at
your training taking
everything into account or just
basically balancing the energy every day
has the same effect towards your goals
in terms of the energy value which
you're consuming it's either gonna
affect performed in the long term or
it's gonna be a slight clock deficit
that's the approaches it was as simple
as it is and that's there was a recent
journal I saw backed up
that's basically what you'd do which is
a great thank you thank you very much I
wasn't sponsored by we dominate what was
not sponsored that's a shitty coca-cola
wander it's probably Big Pharma wasn't
CIA division if they thought the
dangerous though anyway Tim month thank
you very much for coming key I will make
sure linked to we dominate nutrition and
worry programming plus everything else
that we've spoken about will be in the
show notes below if you like to check
him out on Twitter and on Instagram you
want to see onto it an old Twitter don't
exist onto it we can't get on Twitter
though I might start one I might start
one and pretend to be I think you should
just do a fart approach you should just
post what the great that performance is
yeah and just lie about it keep the lies
I've ever just everything can be ate up
but yeah at we don't make nutrition
that's one on Instagram game and yeah
like share you know what to do thank you
very much for tuning in we'll catch you
later on goodbye peace out
[Music]
you